und jetzt schon nach rostock meine damen
und herren die jüngeren verbinden damit
einfach eine hafenstadt an der ostsee wo
die großen kreuzfahrtschiffe anfang
ältere denken bei rostock unweigerlich
an diese bilder an die unfassbaren
ausländerfeindlichen ausschreitungen vor
genau 30 jahren als ostdeutsche
biedermänner zu brandstiftern wurden und
willens waren menschen zu töten nur weil
sie wird nahm esen waren unfassbare vier
tage lang dauerten die ausschreitungen
an die deutsche wiedervereinigung war
gerade ein jahr her es war ein schock
sekunde auch heute hinter dem reporter
des nachrichtensenders welt der gerade
sagt dass rassismus nicht nur ein
rostocker phänomen sei hebt ein 13
jähriger junge auf dem fahrrad den arm
ganz offenbar zum hitlergruß wir kennen
die hintergründe noch nicht aber polizei
und staatsschutz beschäftigen sich mit
dem fall fest steht es passiert direkt
vor dem haus in dem die vietnamesen
damals um ihr leben fürchteten
[Applaus]
rostock lichtenhagen und 24 august 1992
vor der zentralen aufnahmestelle für
asylbewerber gerät ein rechter mob außer
kontrolle
es fliegen steine und molotow cocktails
eine wohnung gerät in brand keine spur
von polizei oder feuerwehr
die menschen in dem haus bangen um ihr
leben höhepunkt eines viertägigen
programms ging ausländer und
asylbewerber die schande von rostock
lichtenhagen der sündenfall der jungen
wiedervereinigten bundesrepublik
das sogenannte sonnenblumenhaus in
rostock lichtenhagen ist 1992 die
zentrale aufnahmestelle für asylbewerber
in mecklenburg vorpommern zudem leben in
dem haus ehemalige vietnamesische
vertragsarbeiter der ddr 1992 dominieren
debatten zu ausländer- und asylpolitik
die öffentliche meinung in ost und west
überall in deutschland heißt es zu
dieser zeit das boot ist voll am frühen
abend des 22
august 1992 ein samstag versammeln sich
bis zu 2000 menschen vor dem
sonnenblumenhaus es kommt zu ersten
angriffen mit brandsätzen und steinen
die polizei kann den mob nicht abdrängen
erst in den frühen morgenstunden rücken
die angreifer erschöpft ab vier tage
lang versucht der mob nun das haus zu
erstürmen es kommt immer wieder zu
straßenschlachten mit der polizei doch
die behörden kapitulieren wir waren
vorbereitet mit polizei aber mit der
polizei können sie diese probleme nicht
lösen und
das war schon so dass aus einer großen
menge von schaulustigen
diese leute die möglichkeiten hatten
angriffe vorzutragen
am montag den 24
1892 gelingt es den angreifern
schließlich in das haus vorzudringen und
es in brand zu setzen bereits am
nachmittag lassen die behörden das
asylbewerberheim evakuieren nur noch das
wohnheim der vietnamesische
vertragsarbeiter ist zu diesem zeitpunkt
bewohnt die polizei versucht den platz
vor dem sonnenblumenhaus zu räumen doch
die gewalt eskaliert mit brandsätzen und
steinen werden die beamten angegriffen
bis sie sich schließlich komplett
zurückziehen niemand kann den rechten
pöbel jetzt noch aufhalten von applaus
und johlen begleitet werden steine und
molotow-cocktails in das wohnheim der
vietnamesen geworfen der eingangsbereich
wurde gestürmt türen eingetreten fenster
eingeworfen im inneren des hauses
versuchen die eingeschlossenen in
todesangst einen ausweg zu finden
nur mit mühe und not können sie sich in
letzter sekunde auf das dach des hauses
retten
erst kurz vor mitternacht kann die
feuerwehr das feuer löschen die polizei
die menschen aus dem haus bringen erst
gegen drei uhr morgens beruhigt sich die
lage
52 polizeibeamte werden verletzt wie
durch ein wunder wird niemand der
bewohner des hauses verletzt auch am
darauf folgenden tag dauern die
auseinandersetzung zwischen polizei und
dem rechten flügel an steine und
brandsätze fliegen bis spät in die nacht
weitere 65 polizisten werden verletzt
bevölkerung in lichtenhagen die hatte
das habt ihr mir den ausländern mit den
dreck hier demnächst wo wir mit leben
muss 30 flaschen in deutschland
abgeschlagen
am rand der ausschreitung entsteht
dieses bild es wurde teil der
kollektiven erinnerung an die
ausschreitung und ist die bekannteste
aufnahme des viertägigen programms ein
bild das um die welt ging eine mahnung
an uns alle
[Musik]